AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
ERIK TOTH: Whoa.
Thanks.
So my name's Eric.
That's me.
So I'm engineering
manager at Paypal.
And I think Dan alluded
to it earlier in his talk,
we've been working with
Node for a couple of years
now, getting it as a first-class
platform to build applications.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit tonight about Node.js
at scale, and I know that
that's a little bit ambiguous.
I think Node.js at scale--
what does that mean?
And in fact, for getting
Node into Paypal,
it meant a lot of things,
but I think the main things
that it meant for
us were scaling
across three
different dimensions.
It wasn't just technology.
It wasn't like we
can pick a technology
and just roll it out.
Everybody would use it
with no loss of products,
and Bob's your uncle.
You just move on from there.
What it actually meant was that
we needed to figure out how
to scale Node and
get across people,
educate a whole lot of people
in JavaScript and Node best
practices, and that meant
transforming C++ and Java
developers into JavaScript
developers and Node developers
as well as bring
front end engineers,
who are well versed
in JavaScript
but didn't necessarily have
a lot of experience building
server side stuff in Node
and understanding the Node
ecosystem and what it really
meant to build applications
at Node.
It also meant that we needed
to look at our processes.
A lot of process where
defined around Java,
around other stacks, and
were built specifically
for those stacks,
wherein you brought Node,
there wasn't really an
analogous-- a proper fit.
So what did that mean for
how our processes were
built over time?
And then finally, we could
really address the technology
and see how can
we integrate Node
into a lot of proprietary stuff
that we run and a lot of not
proprietary stuff, and where
we could take advantage of what
teams have done before and where
we need to forge new ground.
But unfortunately, when you
come to talks like this,
people just want
to see technology.
They want to see code.
But I think one of the better
things about the Node community
and about how you
think about software
and you build
software in Node is
that it's only partially
the technology.
A big portion of it is
around bringing new people
into the fold,
bringing new engineers
into understanding how to write
JavaScript and Node JavaScript,
and mentorship.
And I think one of the
most interesting things
about the community
for me is that there's
a very concerted effort put
towards bringing in people that
either don't know how to
write code in general,
or just never tried it, and
embracing them and saying
that this is something
that's for everybody
and you can build awesome stuff.
And Dan had mentioned
things like Node bots,
the Internet of
Things-- like people
can build stuff, build
anything they want,
with a very straight-- arguably
straightforward language.
We don't want to start that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ERIK TOTH: Yeah, really.
But it's approachable,
and the Node community
has made it more
approachable in my opinion.
So even though the
first two phases
are kind of the boring part
because we want technology,
I'm going to talk about
them a little bit,
at least how they pertain to
Paypal and some of the things
that we've worked through.
So first of all, scaling people,
and when you say like that,
it sounds real weird.
But it's about growing
people, and it's
about educating people and
making people comfortable
working in this environment.
So there's the old analogy,
teach a person to fish--
or give a person a fish,
they eat for a day.
Teach a person-- whatever.
It was very coincidental
that, while writing this,
I remember that my buddy John
Charles wrote this bot that
slaps people with
trouts for Slack.
It's very strange.
This isn't to indicate
that I actually
taught John Charles anything.
He actually teaches
me stuff every day,
but it was something
that reminded me,
like once you have a
team that's tight knit
and people teach each
other all the time,
it's just an incredible
ecosystem which you can grow
and your team can grow.
And you can do things
like slap each other
with fish over Slack.
It's pretty awesome.
But that's all to say that
writing code isn't enough,
and in the macro
level at Paypal,
we had to train hundreds of
engineers, that's one thing.
But then now, I'm a relatively
new engineering manager,
I realize that it's not enough
just to put them in classrooms
and say learn this stuff and
let's go churn out stuff.
It's really important,
and again, I'm
going to tie this back
to the Node community,
that there's this
notion of mentorship,
and there's this notion of
helping everyone around you
grow because when
everybody grows,
the whole ecosystem grows.
So just kind of a wrap-up to
the people thing, something
that I've instituted
on my team, and I'm
hoping to be able to roll
out to other teams on Paypal,
is kind of this
two-phased approach.
And if anybody likes
the idea and wants
to try it on their team,
that'd be incredible.
One is, riffing off of
the Learn You concept,
is every week I
allocate for my team
a certain amount of time
to learn a new technology.
It doesn't matter what it is.
Just learn something
because anything you learn
can be somehow applied
back to your everyday work.
So we do things
like learning Elm,
like learning Rust, like
learning Angular, any front end
frameworks, React.js,
that type of stuff.
And when we talk about it
at the end of the week,
we see how can some
of these concepts
feed back into how
we work with Node
and how we work with other
organizations or teams
around the company and
what that looks like.
So that's every other week,
and then the alternating weeks,
I challenge my team to
contribute code to some project
that either you're
passionate about
or that you use on
a regular basis,
and this is something that has
been huge in the Node community
for me.
And it's directly taught me how
I can not only contribute just
by putting my own
code out there,
but I can contribute by
reading other people's code,
understanding how other
people solve problems,
and then taking that and
either contribute directly
to that or wrapping that
into how I solve problems
and ultimately build
better software.
So as far as wrapping up the
growing people aspect of it,
I think there are
very constructive ways
you can help your team
directly contribute
to the Node community, which
is exceedingly embraces anybody
who wants to contribute,
but also add value
to them personally and
your team as a whole
and make your team
just operate better.
So moving on from
that, the second point,
the second boring point I
guess, is the scaling process,
and this is not to indicate that
process always has to scale up.
In our case, actually,
processes scale down,
and Node was one
of those factors.
And in fact, it was a bit of a
catalyst for some of the things
that scaled down.
So I'm going to
talk about a couple
of specific things that
happened for us at Paypal.
This is not to say that JVM
expertise isn't important.
In my experience, I've
observed that sometimes there
are JVM experts
that exist merely
to wallpaper over the fact that
engineers don't necessarily
pay attention to performance
when they build applications.
Performance is a value add
by another organization
after an application gets built.
That can't hold true with Node.
Engineers need to understand the
consequences of the decisions
when they write software.
They need to
understand, maybe not
quite to the level of Trevor--
that's pretty awesome,
but I don't know that
it's generally applicable.
But they definitely
need to understand
that when I'm writing code, when
I'm interacting with a network
resource, with the file system,
doing anything-- just you're
talking about maybe some
system level stuff isn't
the right fit for
Node, engineers
need to understand
that there are
certain consequences
of their decisions
and that there are some things
that are not a natural fit.
But that's OK.
I don't think it's right to
expect that engineers can just
bang out code, and then somebody
else can clean up after them.
So I think part of
the process thing
is making the process
of educating engineers,
understanding that
there are consequences
to their decisions, and that
right design is-- right design?
That doesn't really make sense.
But that thinking about
design before you start coding
has a meaningful impact, and you
can still build great software,
and you don't have to have
these other guys that come along
and cleanup for people that
just need to meet deadlines
and just, I don't know,
check things off their list.
So let's move on
to the next thing,
and this is not an
anti-Java thing.
This is just from multiple
Java shops that I've worked at.
I've really seen
that, if you have
platforms that take a
lot of time to deploy
and a lot of time for
applications to start
and a lot of time to find
caches and a lot of time
to do all this stuff, you
start designing your system
to have to avoid doing
things like restarts.
And one of things that the Node
community embraces, and it's
generally by virtue
of the fact that you
have small processes
and very discreet things
that your applications
are intended to do,
you no longer have to
worry about accommodating
10 minute, 15 minute
startup times.
You can write applications that
are very good at that thing
that they do, and they can
be resilient to some types
of situations, but they can also
fail and restart very quickly
and take traffic without
much of a hiccup, if any.
And this is really just
about controlling complexity.
There's nothing that wrong
with hot swapping things,
about flushing caches
into other caches.
It's not a bad design.
In a lot of cases,
that's good design.
But there are so many
times that complexity
is added to counter problems
elsewhere in your stack,
like it takes 10 minutes,
15 minutes for applications
to startup.
Not withstanding that,
especially for developer
experiences, if your app takes
10 minutes to start up just
when a developer is
trying to do their work,
they're not going
to get anything
done during the day,
especially when you talk
about the back end to front
end, where engineers are trying
to write HTML JavaScript in
CSS, but they are bound by-- I
got to bounce my server
because I made a change.
That change is a
payload that I need,
and now I go take
a coffee break.
And then the last
kind of big thing
that-- I guess
it's not the last.
Next to the last major
thing that I've noticed,
which I think Node has been a
little bit of a catalyst for,
but it was already happening
to a certain extent,
is-- and again, this is probably
somewhat specific to Paypal.
For people at small
organizations,
you probably don't
run into this.
But there can be a lot
of layers between you
and where your code is
actually running in production.
There can be situations where
you hand off some artifact,
and then it goes
into a black box,
and you find out, OK, it's
running in production.
Go check this system to
find out how it's performing
or whatever.
And there's been
incredible, relating back
to, specifically, Paypal, this
great renaissance of developers
have the control of
their own destiny.
They have control
of their deployment.
They have control of
the code that goes out.
They understand all the
processes, all the steps that
happen between--
when they're ready,
they build their artifact,
they deploy it, it runs.
They can see everything
in that process,
and it gives them
a lot more freedom
to understand-- again tying it
back to the understanding what
your code is doing in
production or having ownership
over things like performance.
When you can see
that transparently,
and you don't have these layers
in between you and your code,
it's really easy to feel
empowered to do something
about it.
And then finally,
this is-- I don't
know if it's a process thing.
I don't know what it is.
But moving from
Maven to NPM is kind
of a big-- it's kind
of awesome, and there's
a little shout out
in there to Kappa.
So at Paypal, we
haven't yet migrated.
We've done the beta
test for NPM Enterprise.
So in the meantime, we've
run our own registry,
and we use a thing we wrote
called Kappa to proxy requests.
So we publish all of our private
modules to one NPM registry,
and then Kappa will check
that registry for a module.
If it doesn't exist,
it'll then check
Public, which gives us nice
separation between where
our proprietary code
lives and Public NPM.
And it turns out that,
for a lot of use cases,
that's really good.
And in fact, for us-- excuse me.
Just to kind of get
a idea of the scale
that people are working
in Node at Paypal,
right now, Kappa
is serving-- and it
may be up because I just
grabbed this number about a week
and a half ago.
We're serving about half
a million pages-- sorry,
half a million packages,
Node modules, per day
through our private
Kappa instance.
So there's a lot of
[INAUDIBLE] and PMIs going on.
There's a lot of builds going on
that are [INAUDIBLE] packages,
and there's a lot of people
that are publishing packages
to our private registry.
So I think it's been a really
interesting observation
to see how processes,
these big processes that
put a lot of people between
you and where your code goes,
have started to erode to support
being able to iterate quickly,
like Dan said, to be able
to observe and understand
performance implications and
really just build applications
very, very quickly and, in a
lot of cases, fairly robustly.
These applications
are pretty good.
So finally, scaling--
now, the technology part,
which probably everybody's here
to talk about or here about.
So Scaling Node.js-- so
I doubt anybody knows me
personally from my involvement
in the Node community.
Maybe some do, but
Paypal had introduced--
it's been a while now,
maybe a year and a half.
--this kind of frameworky thing
that sits on top of Express
called Kraken.js.
So Kraken.js was our
attempt to help scale Node
across our organization, not
from a performance perspective,
but take some of
the tribal knowledge
out of setting up web
application servers
and make it a repeatable
processes that you could have
a predictable
application by default
and let application
developers focus
on building great products
and not think about wiring up
all the low level
details that it
takes to just get a baseline
robust server going.
So that happened about
a year and a half ago.
We're definitely
making progress.
We're not still stuck there.
Right now, we have about
30 web applications
running in production.
Some notable examples
are our homepage.
It's not yet at 100%
traffic, but they're
ramping up right now.
Interesting kind
of hand-wavy stat
that, only because I don't
think I can say actual numbers,
is that they're on a
trajectory to use about half
the number of servers
that were needed
for the previous version that
was written in Java, which
is a pretty awesome feat,
especially since traffic
has grown since we were
running in Java before.
And that's actually prior
to any optimization passes.
They're right now
at the point where
they're running optimization
passes over their application
and focusing on very
specific bottlenecks,
so that's been a really
encouraging thing.
Things like the consumer
customer homepage, My Account
page when you log in, 100%
US-- I think I wrote it down.
Maybe not.
--US, UK, and Germany I
think, 100% of traffic
all running on Node.
So we've got a couple of
applications running on Node.
We've got a couple people
that know how to write apps.
We've been able to
scale it pretty well,
but there's definitely
been hiccups along the way.
And I'm not sure--
I'm going to say it,
that I think other than actual
programming errors, the lion's
share of issues that you
run into with scaling Node
all come back to some
form of back pressure,
whether it's CPU constraints
that you have-- it's basically
resource constraints based
on decisions that you make.
So I have a lot of
network connections,
and my downstream services
can't handle the load.
This is why I consume resources
just by virtue of the fact
that I have thousands of
concurrent connections open,
or I'm doing a lot of
template rendering,
like Trevor mentioned.
So my CPU is bound
by some work that I'm
doing that really has nothing to
do with my core business value
issue.
It's something that's a
side effect of needing
to render pages or whatever.
So one of the things that
we're trying to focus on
is finding ways to
address those bottlenecks
and allow teams to still
build applications quickly,
but help fix some of
those potential pitfalls
of back pressure.
So one of the things that
I've been working on recently,
that hopefully is
going to be rolled out,
is this module called Levee.
Now, we're going to get
into code a little bit.
So if anybody's familiar with
the circuit breaker pattern,
this is based off of, actually,
an existing module out there,
and I'm going to look
at his name quickly.
I guess I can't.
Not going to bounce out of this.
There is a Node
circuit breaker module
that this is heavily
influenced by.
It's really good.
I just had another direction
that I wanted to take,
so I decided to
try my hand at it.
But what a circuit
breaker pattern
is, is if I have an
application that's
talking to services--
actually, before I go on
with that, circuit breaker in
Node, and actually in Netflix,
is Histrix, is a JVM
based implementation
of this same pattern,
which is pretty awesome.
So this is just my crack
at making it for Node.
But basically, if I
have a service that
exceeds its SLA on
the client, I can
observe-- let's say I have
five requests timeout.
I can actually trip
the circuit breaker
and put it into an
open state, meaning
I will fast fail
subsequent connections
for a certain amount of time.
After a certain amount
of time has elapsed,
I will allow a single request
through as kind of a smoke test
to see if that
application has recovered.
If it has, great.
The breaker closes,
and I resume traffic.
If it hasn't, I go
ahead and reset,
and then after a certain
amount of time, I try again.
So this is a really
interesting way
of dealing with back pressure,
where instead of just timing
out and keeping a
ton of connections
open, or the
application goes down,
and I just get thousands
of econ reset errors,
I can actually set up a fallback
mechanism that allows me to put
in a fake payload or
some sort of message
that I can use for
my internal clients
or my code in my application,
but also doesn't repeatedly
hammer my API's or my services
such that they can't recover.
It takes the traffic
burden away for them.
So if they need to be restarted,
or if they're just slowing down
because they can't
handle that traffic,
it gives them that
built-in recovery time.
So a quick just very
fast example of this
is-- so this is an example using
the REQ module by the Happy.js
crew, [INAUDIBLE].
So normally, you'd
just write req dot get,
and you have this
thing called downtime
because it's not up very often.
And you get back after calling.
You're getting your stats.
You get an error,
you get a response,
and then you get the payload.
So with Levee, I grayed out
the stuff that doesn't change.
You can wrap the GET call
in this Create Breaker,
so you have this circuit
breaker instance.
So now, you can call the
same API, circuit dot run,
and you give it the call.
And after a certain
number of failures
in this particular
configuration,
you'll still get
an error message,
but after those failures,
the error message
will say I'm not calling that
anymore and just fast failing
because the service is down,
and there's nothing I can do.
And it doesn't make sense for
me to use resources and keep
connections open on a
service that may take 5 or 10
minutes to return
or just be down.
So that's the first pass,
but then the second pass
is I can configure
a fallback now.
So if I had this
Create Breaker before,
I can then create a fallback
that is always successful.
So I don't have to then think
about, well, what if it's down,
I get error messages back.
I may get a few error
messages at the beginning
until I hit that threshold,
but after that, I've
got a backup payload
that will suffice
for running my application,
or at least notifying
the rest of my application
that this service is down
for a certain amount of time.
So again, this is
something that we're
going to be tryout at Paypal.
Netflix has used this
pattern with great success.
And I think when we're
talking about Node,
and we're talking
about performance,
something about back
pressure being a major issue,
and even if you talk to the
Walmart guys on Black Friday,
the Node process
isn't the problem.
It's the fact that it
can send traffic so fast
to other applications
that may not
be able to deal with that
amount of traffic that
could potentially
become the issue.
So I'm a big fan of the
circuit breaker pattern.
I'm going to run through
these next two things
really quickly because
I'm going a little over,
but Dan very briefly talked
about API's and about REST
API's and REST specifications.
So another thing that a guy
on my team is working on,
Trevor Livingston, is this
thing called Swaggerize Express,
and it's a spec first
approach to building services,
to building RESTful services.
So at Paypal, part of the
process of building a service
is you define the
API for that service,
and you iterate on
that design before you
start writing code, which
is really boring for people
that like to write code.
But on the other hand,
what that means is
you have a document that is
the canonical representation
of your API, from which
documentation falls out,
from which your
implementation can fall out,
and from which client API's or
client modules can fall out.
So when we thought
about it, we thought,
all right, well, everybody
is spending this time putting
effort into building
this document.
How about we use that
document to not only drive
the generation of
these apps, but then
drive the validation of these
endpoints, the validation
of the inputs and
outputs, and continue
to use that document
as a canonical resource
to describe the API for
both clients and servers,
but then also to help ensure
that these apps are stable when
they're being built
and then when they're
running in production?
So just a quick
snippet of code--
it doesn't really describe much.
Basically, you just use
it with Express right now.
The API JSON is your
Swagger document
that describes your API,
assumes that you've already
run the generation
step, and you've
built out the
scaffolding for the API.
You have a reference
to your handlers
and then a reference
to your documentation.
And then finally,
it's a working name.
I don't think
[INAUDIBLE] has come up
with a-- I think we're still
working on the name for it
right now.
But another thing
that we've observed
when running applications
in production,
specifically web
applications, is
that it's important
to instrument your app
to understand what it's
doing in production,
but more importantly, is
instrumenting your app
to understand what
business value it's
adding, which means
that you're potentially
doing a lot more
logging of specific data
as it pertains to what's
flowing through the app.
Not is my app healthy, how
much memory is it using;
but is my app actually
fulfilling the metrics
that the product
team has established
for what it should be doing?
So when you're talking about
doing a lot of logging,
we have a lot of services
that are socket based,
that are REST based.
I guess none of that matters.
What matters is
what we've observed
is people will either write
just giant JSON objects
or they'll write a lot of code
to pluck individual values out
of these gigantic
payloads in order
to do this type of reporting.
And some teams just
hand rule this property
on this property
on this property,
and they write this really
really brittle thing
that traverses this
giant JSON structure.
Some teams use an
existing implementation
of JSON path, which
unfortunately is
the source of some
CPU contention,
very heavily regular expression
based implementation,
and also does this
parsing of the selector
and the evaluation of the
data in the same step.
So what [INAUDIBLE] came up with
was something that breaks that
into two steps, and
you use the selector
to compile an evaluator.
And then at runtime,
you run the evaluator
your object, meaning that we can
get these giant payloads back,
JSON payloads back,
from our services.
We can write a selector
that plucks off
individual values
from that payload
and then just logs what it needs
with as little CPU overhead
as possible and, more
importantly, less brittle
logging code spread all
over our application.
So that's just a quick example
of transposer dot create.
So you create your
implementation
based on the selector, and
then at runtime, you just
run it over the
data but you want.
And just a couple
of stats for what
she's been able to do with it,
the existing implementation
the team is using for--
so this is recursively
select any property
with the name ID
is what this top one is.
She's been able to improve it.
This is her module.
This is the existing module.
And we're hoping
that, again bringing
that back to the no.js scale,
to be able to grab data
at runtime, do logging
without any or minimal effect
to the customer experience.
Hopefully, this will
help us get that far.
But anyway, so
that's all I have.
Kind of rambling
quick, but hopefully,
it gave everybody
some insight into how
we've been able to
scale Node at Paypal.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: All
right, thank you Eric.
Cool.
So Guillermo's just
getting mic'd up here.
Once again, so another
about half an hour,
take a quick break after that.
And then we'll do the Q&A
with all the speakers.
Are there any quick
questions for Eric
while we're setting up?
Eric, come on back.
Any quick questions here?
Yep?
Go for it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you [INAUDIBLE]?
ERIK TOTH: So the
question was I had
given this kind of high
level statistics of it's
been taking less machines to
drive the Node implementation
of a particular
application, but it had JVM.
The specific thing that
I attribute that to
is that the application did
not a ton of business logic,
but really the logic was
around composing pages.
So it was very amenable
to large caches
and just literally writing
buffers out to the response.
It made some service
calls, not as
many as our other
heavyweight applications.
It's a small plug to
Kraken, but the fact
that it's based on a very
lightweight thing instead
of-- to say that
it's faster than JVM
makes a lot of assumptions.
We have frameworks built on top
of frameworks in any platform.
For our particular
implementation,
the fact that Kraken
was lightweight for what
they needed based on Express,
that it didn't provide
any features they
didn't need, it just
inherently had a
lot of less overhead
to do that specific task.
It could mostly be attributed
to our implementation
on top of the JVM, but it
was just an observation
that, for our business, half
the servers is half the servers.
It is what it is.
But it was a little
hand-wavy, I agree,
and it really depends
on your implementation.
It depends on the stack that you
build within your organization.
But as a direct
report for us, it
was a really big win
at the end of the day.
So cool.
All right.